imagine someone coming into your kitchen
and taking a few tools a pan and your
garbage
then they bury everything in the woods
twelve thousand years later an
archaeologist is trying to figure out
who you were
what was important to you what video
games you played what you believed in
and what informed your decisions
because you happened to live during a
remarkable time in human history
the planetary revolution when humanity
transitioned becoming a multi-planetary
species
in that time our numbers would explode
by orders of magnitude our technology
and standard of living would improve to
levels previously thought impossible and
our self-conception would change forever
and all the future archaeologist has to
learn about is your junk in the woods
while we can only hope that this will be
someone's problem in twelve thousand
years we have the same problem today
we're trying to reconstruct a revolution
that took place 12 000 years ago
today only shadows remain of the people
who experienced our distant past as
their present
what remains from our past
we can look at our present in crispy 4k
in color and sound
three generations ago the world was just
black and white
one more generation and we see the world
through blurred photographs
further back paintings and texts become
our main way of experiencing the past
a mere 20 generations before us today
every written word had to be copied by
hand and reports became more scarce and
less reliable
the first historian lived a mere 100
generations ago
before him there are only epics and
legends and dead kings bragging on
pieces of stone
250 generations ago there are only
fragments left in the ground and images
stripped to their original meaning
eventually humanity becomes basically
invisible
still we do know some things about our
ancestors
let's try to tell their story and what
it means for us today
the greatest transition in human history
for some 2 million years or roughly 80
000 generations the life of our
ancestors was basically the same
it was around 20 000 years or 800
generations ago that the behaviorally
modern humans began a process that would
change our lifestyle forever at first
gradually for some of us
then faster for more of us and then
suddenly for almost all of us
back then there were about one million
modern humans on earth
most other human species had died out
probably with a little help from us
our ancestors biology had given them the
necessary tools
a general intelligence to understand
things a social intelligence to
understand each other and language to
express abstract ideas and create new
concepts
these were people just like you
they suffered and experienced joy were
bored cried and laughed
they lived in communities of a few dozen
people
they controlled fire and had tools made
from wood stone and bone told stories
mourned their dead and created art
they traded with other tribes from
obsidian to shellfish
some hunted big game and were very
mobile others relied more on plants they
collected and others mostly stayed in
one area with an abundance of seafood
this was the common state of humanity
for most of our history
until a slow transition step by step
turned into a revolution
[Music]
step by step
the first solid evidence for this stems
from the jordan valley where our
ancestors collected wild wheat more than
20 000 years ago
they noticed that seeds in the ground
made more plants the next year if they
put good ones in one place the next year
they had more of the good ones
this was a great supplement to hunting
and gathering
you could prepare some crops return next
year build a temporary settlement and
have a secure food supply
our ancestors used these bonus crops to
bake the first bread and brew the first
beer
with every generation they gathered
deeper knowledge about the plants and
animals around them and how to
manipulate them to their advantage
but there was a lot to learn
very slowly from generation to
generation pockets of knowledge expanded
and were passed along to be expanded
again
this early agriculture started to
drastically reduce the space our
ancestors needed to feed one individual
which made it possible to stay in one
place longer
around 12 000 years ago these little
pieces of progress had reached a
critical mass
most of the calories we consume today
stem from about 15 different founder
crops that humans began to domesticate
in earnest in the next few thousand
years
what we call the agricultural revolution
was not a thing that began suddenly one
day it was a slow process driven by
small groups over many generations
eventually gradual change gave rise to a
new era
the human era
during the next few thousand years
progress would speed up and turn
hunter-gatherers into farmers who lived
in villages towns and then cities
when farmers moved into new areas they
replaced the nomadic tribes or turned
them into farmers too
this was neither easy nor painless
in the early days people had a diverse
diet made up of up to 250 different
plants and animals
for some of the groups transitioning to
agriculture the variation in their diets
declined drastically and some even seem
to have been undernourished
and living close together and with
animals created a breeding ground for
disease
virtually every infectious disease
caused by microorganisms that have
adapted to humans arose in the last 10
000 years
cholera smallpox measles influenza
chickenpox and malaria
mortality especially among children rose
drastically
still our numbers grew because living in
the same place enabled women to bear far
more children than before and for a
farmer more kids mean more hands to work
the fields
even with more people dying younger
villages and towns grew the number of
humans on earth exploded
about 100 generations after the
beginning of the human era there were
already four million of us
this increased the need for food and
forced people to come up with ever more
efficient ways of producing calories
solidifying our new lifestyle
going back to hunting and gathering
would have just meant death by
starvation for most
one question remains unanswered why
why would people exchange the freedom of
living off nature with a huge variety in
food for the grind of agriculture and
often more limited diets
nobody knows for sure
climate change seems to have made the
transition possible and some scientists
argue that it was caused by external
factors like undernourishment or
overpopulation both highly contested
today the most widely accepted idea is
that it was a deliberate choice made by
countless communities around the globe
maybe it's also connected with what
makes us human
the ability to come together develop
shared identities and exchange stories
and knowledge
some archaeologists think that groups of
hunter-gatherers traveled long and far
to celebrate to hold feasts and rituals
they would have used these occasions to
talk about their version of innovation
better hunting and tool making
techniques how to catch and breed
animals and which plants could be
collected and multiplied maybe they even
exchanged seeds
it's not unlikely that these gatherings
were the catalyst that spread the
knowledge of agriculture through the
many isolated groups of humanity
ultimately ending a lifestyle that was
common to our species for thousands of
generations
so by being able to come together
celebrate share and learn from one
another these humans might have taken
the steps that led to our modern world
and we have much to be grateful for
we are still the same humans today even
if it often doesn't feel that way
maybe it's time to come together to
share what we know and celebrate our
existence once again to begin another
peaceful transition maybe the planetary
revolution that will change everything
once more
so hopefully in another 12 000 years our
descendants will look back on us today
with gratitude for the amazing world
they are able to inhabit
to celebrate the achievements of our
ancestors in the last 12 000 years and
look with hope towards the next 12 000
we present you with the fifth human era
calendar for the year 12021
this time it's all about the journey of
humanity
beginning tens of thousands of years ago
leading into the revolution of
agriculture to ancient high
civilizations and the beginning of
modern times culminating in a vision for
our future
you can get the limited edition now
until we sell out and then never again
as always the calendar features 12
illustrated pages printed on high
quality paper in europe and the us
and this year the cover is especially
shiny
not only does the calendar look great on
walls and makes it easier to dream about
a glorious future and realize how far
we've come as a species it's also the
best way to support kotzkazak the
calendar enables us to put in the time
our videos need and release them for
free for everyone
if you want you can get the calendar
with a hoodie or infographic posters or
plushie we've made a few deals for you
thank you so much to the thousands of
people who get the calendar every year
and to the burbs who love what we try to
do on this channel
we wish you a happy year
12021 and let's all hope that it will be
less exciting than
twenty